un mois et demi qu'il n'a pas ouvert ses
portes au public
comme toutes les salles obscures de
france le cinéma de quartier les cinq
caumartin fait lui aussi les frais du
coronavirus malgré la fermeture son
directeur continue de faire tourner les
projecteurs
une fois par semaine le cinéma ça
commerce qui ne ferme jamais
même le jaune s'est pas fait pour être
éteints donc certains matériaux à
l'intérieur on va être allumé une fois
par semaine parce que pour remettre les
horloges
numérique à l'heure et plein d'autres
choses parce que c'est vraiment pas fait
c'est paraissent des machines qui sont
pas faites pour être éteinte pendant
vers le cinéma n'a jamais été aussi
longtemps le lieu d'ordinaire si animé
désormais vidée de sa clientèle une
période très compliquée pour le
personnel en chômage partiel
malgré des aides du gouvernement
l'avenir du cinéma restent floues c'est
sûr qu'on va t-on vers damas le cinéma a
je pense 30% de sa capacité pour les
gestes barrières parce que je pense que
la prochaine il y aura une rangée sur
deux un siège sur trois enfin un jour ne
s'est pas encore penché encore c'est des
suppositions et donc c'est sûr qu'on va
démarrer avec un chiffre d'affaires très
bas donc avoir une aide au moins du
redémarrage quoi ça reste une fête et un
endroit agréable que ce soit pas obligé
et on fera mieux est vraiment mieux pour
pour les spectateurs on a déjà commencé
à commander des masques pour notre
premier collaborateur
on a commandé des gels hydroalcooliques
et on est en train de changer tout le
système de chasse d'eau s'est pas
beaucoup n'ont pas besoin de toucher on
a train de changer nos systèmes sèche
mains enfin c'est vraiment en train
d'investir et sa d'investissement il
assez lourd pour une petite entreprise
comme la nôtre je le vis très très mal
enfin je parce que le cinéma est un
comme ça j'avais jamais vu ça je suis
une famille d'exploitants
j'avais jamais vu un cinéma étant aussi
longtemps samuel mer le prend son mal en
patience en attendant le feu vert de
l'état qui doit statuer sur la
réouverture ou non des cinémas le 2 juin
prochain